spider-man no way home is set to throw
steven strange and peter parker into a
whole new adventure together but what's
the comic book background to these two
characters long-running friendship this
is the untold truth of spider-man and dr
strange's relationship
the first time spider-man and doctor
strange were shown working together on
the printed page was in 1965's amazing
spider-man annual number two this
marvelous team-up featured the
webslinger and the sorcerer supreme
pitting their wits and powers against a
sinister magic user named zandu who
sought to steal a powerful artifact from
the sanctum sanctorum after foiling the
villain's plans in an interdimensional
battle strange pledges his allegiance to
spider-man planting the seed that would
grow into a close friendship
chronologically however spider-man and
strange's first adventure together may
have been much earlier having been
depicted in 1998's untold tales of
spider-man strange encounters in this
flashback story strange enlists the wall
crawler's assistance in recovering the
mystical lantern of lantar which some
thugs stole from a museum due to an
earlier encounter with the lantern
wielding crooks spider-man senses have
become attuned to the ancient object's
location the trail leads to one of
strange's most dangerous foes baron
mordo who plans to offer human
sacrifices to his patron enigma in
exchange for ultimate power in the end
the two heroes defeat mordo strange
subsequently erases the memories of
mordo's captives at spider-man's request
even though it means they'll forget
spidey's heroics this selfless act makes
strange realize that there's more to
this young man than meets the eye
of all the tricks hidden up doctor
strange's billowy sleeves his hero
summoning tarot cards are perhaps the
most exciting when faced with incredible
threats that even he can't handle alone
strange uses his cards to assemble an
impromptu team known as the secret
defenders the roster changes depending
on who the cards reveal more often than
not the selected players are the heroes
who are best equipped to deal with the
menace at hand in issues number six to
number eight of secret defenders strange
enlists the aid of spider-man and the
scarlet witch to stop his persistent
foes zandu from enacting his latest plan
to merge earth with the death dimension
and rule them both the cards initially
pick ghostrider as the fourth member of
the roster but strange is unable to
contact him instead captain america
joins the team after accidentally
stumbling upon some magical chaos during
his nightly patrol with the aid of the
magical wand of wutoom zandu nearly
succeeds in his plot however thanks to a
last minute strategy that strange and
captain pull off zandia's former lover
melinda becomes the queen of the death
dimension feeling disgust over zandu's
actions she casts him out of the death
dimension permanently ending his brief
but tumultuous ring
spider-man is used to facing all kinds
of danger but even he acknowledges that
magical menaces are a little above his
pay grade well i i mean i'm i'd rather
just stay on the ground for a little
while friendly neighborhood spider-man
somebody's gotta look out for the little
guy right so whenever these mystical
threats pop up in his corner of the
world he's more than happy to receive
assistance from the sorcerer's supreme
one noteworthy example of this occurred
in the three-part story happy birthday
which ran from amazing spider-man vol 2
number 57 to amazing spider-man vol 1
number 500 after being soundly defeated
and scattered across various dimensions
by strange the evil being dormammu
tricks new york's heroes into helping
him reconstitute himself as swarms of
his mindless ones overrun manhattan a
mystical mishap knocks spider-man and
doctor strange outside of time and space
using a spell strange takes spider-man
through his whole past up to the exact
moment at which all hell broke loose
spider-man successfully prevents the
heroes from releasing dormammu with only
the sorcerer and the webslinger having
any recollection of what transpired as a
reward for his help strange hands
spiderman a tiny golden chest when he
opens it he receives the best surprise
of his life a few minutes with his uncle
ben who tells him just how proud he is
of the man peter has become
during marvel's civil war event
spider-man does the unthinkable in
support of the superhuman registration
act pioneered by tony stark he publicly
unmasks and tells the world that he is
peter parker unsurprisingly this
decision proves to be a huge mistake as
his aunt may is hit by a bullet courtesy
of one of the kingpin's assassins as the
life of his longtime mother figure hangs
in the balance peter seeks the aid of
doctor strange to save her unfortunately
strange admits he can do nothing to save
her life he helps peter reach out to the
marvel universe's other geniuses but
they all give him the same answer aunt
may is going to die so out of pure
desperation peter parker strikes a deal
with the demon mephisto to save his
dying aunt in return the demonic ruler
asks for peter's marriage with mary jane
watson which he deems as the rarest
purest love of all to hold up his end of
the bargain mephisto rewrites history so
that the marriage never happened in this
new reality doctor strange mr fantastic
and iron man merge science and magic to
make the world forget spider-man's
secret identity
in the concluding chapter of one moment
in time strange works with tony stark
and mr fantastic to infect the world
with a virus infused spell designed to
make everyone forget spider-man's secret
identity except for peter parker and
mary jane watson sound familiar entire
world is about to forget the peter
parker spider-man of course all of this
is rooted in peter's deal with mephisto
but no one not even peter himself
remembers that the demon is involved
regardless this ushers in a brand new
day for the webslinger a clean slate of
sorts that would remain largely intact
for over a decade in real time that is
until the events of amazing spider-man
vol 5 number 51 came to pass in order to
free his spider-powered allies from the
thrall of a literal villain from hell
called kindred spider-man consults
strange who attempts to cast a spell
with a mystical item to help him
surprisingly the spell fails prompting
strange to wonder if the wall crawler
has ever unknowingly struck any mystical
deals in the past strange's suspicions
lead him to the door of the hotel
inferno in las vegas mephisto's earthly
base of operations there he asks
mephisto point blank to tell him what's
wrong with peter parker's soul for a
while the infernal lord refuses to give
strange any straight answers even after
losing a wager with the source for a
supreme over the outcome of the
so-called sinister war their game
continues soon after however and strange
eventually manages to put a stop to
mephisto's plans and free spider-man
from the demon's control only then is it
revealed why mephisto targeted peter and
mj's relationship in the first place
because he fears the power of their
potential child
spider-man and doctor strange have
worked together on multiple occasions
showing off their best and worst
qualities to each other in the process
interestingly the good doctor has also
had the opportunity to collaborate with
two of the webslinger's most prominent
copycats both of whom were products of
science gone wrong in the 2017 limited
series damnation strange's longtime ally
wong assembles a temporary team of
supernatural heroes to save las vegas
from being overtaken by mephisto's
minions in the nick of time the team is
saved from certain doom by the scarlet
spider aka peter parker's clone ben
reilly together they are able to find
doctor strange and restore las vegas to
its normal state the sorcerer supreme
has also allied himself with another
superlative using superhero the superior
spider-man a reformed doctor octopus
occupying a perfect clone body of peter
parker in 2019 superior spider-man vol 2
number 5 the eye of agamotto reveals the
true identity of the san francisco-based
vigilante strange after strange calls
for spider-man's help initially
apprehensive to work with a notorious
criminal strange and the superior
spider-man set aside their differences
and save the day their shared adventure
ends with strange giving some
well-meaning advice to the arrogant hero
about honesty and accountability
during spider-man's brief but memorable
time in his symbiote costume peter
parker went on quite a few adventures
some which he barely remembers himself
one of these untold chapters of his life
was brought to light in the 2020 limited
series symbiote spider-man alien reality
which also revealed that at one point he
actually received training in the mystic
arts from dr strange himself waking up
to a bizarre world he barely recognizes
a symbiote-clad spider-man rushes to the
sanctum sanctorum hoping to get some
clarity from strange what he finds there
shocks him the hobgoblin his longtime
foe has become the apprentice of a
different sorcerer supreme and strange
himself is nowhere to be found
eventually the paths of the spider and
the true sorcerer supreme cross and
strange explains how the world was
transformed by a powerful book called
the word of god
together they concoct a plan to set the
world right again which includes
teaching spider-man a few defensive
spells to give him a fighting chance
against his newly mystic powered foe
strange and spider-man managed to defeat
hobgoblin and his master baron mordo
with some assistance from the
otherworldly being called nightmare
however spider-man retains no memory of
the events that transpired including the
spells he learned under strange
kid an avenger now
in his early years spider-man made a
number of attempts to join the avengers
each with varying levels of success
prior to 2005 the closest he had gotten
to becoming a card-carrying avenger was
becoming a reserve member in 1991's
avengers number 329 that changed however
when he joined the new avengers as a
full-time member alongside captain
america iron man spider woman luke cage
wolverine and the century not too long
after spider-man found himself joining
hands with his longtime magical ally
doctor strange new avengers number 27
features the debut of the latest
renegade avengers team as they rescue
their newest recruit echo from elektra
and the hand driven underground after
the events of the superhuman civil war
this team of new avengers operates from
strange's sanctum sanctorum while
evading arrest at the hands of the
government sanctioned team avengers led
by iron man
once upon a time whenever spider-man and
doctor strange teamed up it was almost a
given that their adventures would
involve some form of inter-dimensional
travel in modern times however
spider-man has found himself unassisted
by the sorcerer's supreme while crossing
the boundaries of the marvel multiverse
or to be more specific the spider-verse
while the concept of a room full of
spider-man teaming up was in 1994's
spider-man the animated series the first
time that comic books would adapt the
idea on a comparable scale was in the
2014 multi-part spider-verse crossover
the story features the main spider-man
peter parker on earth 616 reaching out
to various spider people across time in
space and enlisting their aid in a no
holds barred battle against the psychic
vampire morlan but hey with friends like
these who needs steven strange
the cooperative relationship between
spider-man and doctor strange would also
be reflected in the dystopian world of
2099 by their future counterparts in
fact the timely interference of one ends
up saving the other from pre-destined
death the spider-man of 2099 miguel
o'hara is a gifted but arrogant
geneticist who begins his heroic journey
after a sabotaged lab experiment grants
him spider powers meanwhile the
self-proclaimed sorceress supreme of
2099 is a young woman named jeannie who
trained herself in the mystic arts when
spider-man 2099 and strange 2099 first
meet in the pages of spider-man 2099
number 32 the sorceress asks for the aid
of the s-man in putting a stomp to a
zombie invasion in mexico city after
this adventure the two heroes would find
themselves teaming up from time to time
fighting against such foes as the
maestro the murderous future version of
the hulk however the most crucial piece
of assistance that spider-man 2099 ever
receives from the sorceress supreme
happens in the final issue of his
eponymous comic's third volume
sustaining near-fatal injuries in a
present-day battle against his mutated
hypnotized lover tempest miguel is saved
from certain death by a last minute
spell cast by strange 2099. by the time
spider-man 2099 wakes up his injuries
have been healed and he has been
transported to strange's headquarters in
the year 2100 it just goes to show no
matter where and when they might be
spider-man and doctor strange are
destined to be best of buds
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]